eight year NFL veteran who was here a
couple weeks ago in studio here on the
program how you doing Jeff I'm good so
another entering the preseason match
it's a bummer it's a bummer what do you
think the win injury means for the
offensive line in New England Jeff well
they lost Nate soldier and I know that
when was at right tackle which he had
not really played much in his career I
thought he played left but they got
Trent Browns they put into the left
tackle so it's gonna hurt I mean you
know knowing when it had issues the last
couple years or they're off until how
about this Tom Brady has basically
played I think I looked this up last
season almost every single game of his
career as it has that either Matt Light
or Nate soldier as his left hackles -
about eight games in his career so the
example used to playing with new guys up
front and this Isaiah wouldn't pick 23rd
overall from Georgia kids really good
unfortunately it won't have a services
this year so what do you think Belichick
and his offensive line group is is doing
today I mean what do you think I can
plug and play here they still have I
believe they still have Marcus cannon
there so he'll play right tackle for now
and and they'll just try to either trade
the symbol or doing what is always with
trading but we've seen you know
in this first couple of weeks of
pre-season there's no definite that's
not offensive lives I don't even know
who they would possibly trade for nor
would a team I didn't want to trade any
of their depth we saw with the trend
Brown traded - drafted Mike McCoy to
play tackles we had a surplus of tackles
in Trent Brown does not fit at all what
college in hand who wants to do on his
offensive line so it made sense for that
guy to be traded otherwise that's why
you draft guys while you bring the for
ages and you don't get buy-in and keep
Tom Brady healthy I mean it's it's so
impressive even after seeing a thick
poles go down and Carson Wentz might not
be back just the longevity of Tom Brady
and doing one and just not getting hurt
you had that one year but other what's
the healthy well you have an interesting
theory as to how something like this
happens with Isaiah win and why we
sometimes see offensive linemen hurt
their ankles and feet
Achilles etc Jeff I'll give you the
floor on that yeah so it's obviously a
hard theory to prove but I've talked to
a buddy of mine who's
about this and you know he was playing a
position a right tackle and he had not
played his entire career he's been a
left guard left tackle in high school in
college and he missed all the spring
ball doing wonders for a shoulder injury
his rehab and so he comes out during
training camp when his right tackle and
just getting used to the new body
mechanisms of playing that position I
think led to this now is it a direct
cause no but it's hard to switch
positions up front I had the same thing
happen to me at play right tackle right
guard my entire career I played one game
at left guard in 2013 weirdly enough
against the Giants I wasn't came to see
I get to New York the right time the
right guard retires I asked to play
there they tell me no appoint left guard
I just never got used to it and then I
injured my my big toe dislocated trying
to anchor bulrush and left guard like
right guard I switched my feet which are
not supposed to do obviously but just
ingrained in me for so long for 89 10
years put my foot back my toe pops out I
mean I don't know what else to say I
mean that's a direct correlation there
it's a move I never would have done it
right and my car would have been fine
over there so it's unfortunately
happened and the idea that offensive
lineman could just switch sides and
everything to be okay
is not Donald Penn's trying to do it now
in Oakland that just at hey you play the
hundred six games in a row at left
tackle go play right tackle now it's not
that easy it's play about tackle for 13
15 16 years now including college put
him in will of tackle put the rookie
right tackle for now Jeff Schwartz
eight years in the NFL as an offensive
lineman here on the Rich Eisen show okay
what do you you think of what
Cleveland's doing at quarterback Jeff
well I I don't know what they're doing
in general as a team I think in Hard
Knocks typically sends a good light on
your your program and your organization
I don't think it sends a very good light
on you Jackson at all they have no idea
what they're doing they they rest they
rest guys the fourth day miles miles
Gary they play Holloway the whole game
as punishment
Todd Haley's openly bickering with you
over other handling practice time he's
not the only coaches doing that and then
you know they announce Baker Mason's
gonna get no reps with the ones at all
we saw a Sam Donald here up to the one
last night and maybe maybe but Townes
was harder for the year but least you
got to see Donald with the
against the one defense of the Redskins
Josh Rosen's gonna gear up to the ones
because he's often talkative so for with
the twos guys you guys are the one and
the browser suck no we're good first
pick overall who cares
we only rep to the ones and look last
year with Alex Smith and Pat Mahone
that's what they're trying to have this
be but the Chiefs were in the playoff
hunt they won the division last year the
Browns are not winning in Division you
drafted Baker Mayfield to clay him
hi Ron Taylor is a big boy he
understands the situation they'll have
to assure Co things for him but did not
to not give your number one pick looks
like he is ready to take reps with the
one and all in training camp business
malpractice what happens when when
you're Owen - after playing the Saints
and and the Steelers are the wings
wanted to they're those lips but one and
two and your own - and fans are calling
for your head and put Baker Mayfield ad
well he's practiced none at all with any
of the ones whatsoever um it just makes
no sense to me
well they've talked about maybe putting
stroke Drew Stanton in there instead yes
I don't I don't like your you're in the
position to do asset and number one
quarterback because you suck a
quarterback that's why you want to walk
one in 31 the last few years you eat a
quarterback and he looks like he is
ready to play I understand it is really
far off with a million Josh Alomar
Jackson don't look quite ready yet even
Josh Rosen us first he looked quite
ready yet
but he looks ready to play and Tyler
Taylor is not the future you don't have
to be nice to him I understand it look
want to be nice to this guy a great guy
and a great leader but trade it for him
and you don't know whether you got one
you left on his deal play the guide you
drafted he's ready to play you have a
good offense I want to have weapons are
still concerned to be as far as injury
or lack of development because those
skill players around him well Jeff
Schwartz what do you think about what
the Jets are doing you mentioned
obviously you seed Arnold with the ones
you mentioned McDowell may be the
starter what about Bridgewater I mean he
looked great I think Donald should be
the guy week one and Bridgewater would
be in the position of understanding or
maybe traded to his spot that could use
him what do you think about the Jets
quarterback scenario you're Jeff I think
Bridgewater obviously played well it was
really funny I fell asleep before that
game last night and I woke up this
morning and I thought I told her I want
the Superbowl of people tweeting out
there whoever is going to sign is going
to go 12 and 4 that's kind of
quite well or horribly seized a game I
think the team was great for him 100% I
think that with new challenge contract
5,000,000 guarantee he's staying
Sam Drona will start and go there's
teams around NFL look look at the Eagles
if you know people come up full shoulder
being more serious and thought Carson
Wentz is not ready to play yet traded
for Bridgewater this locking Sena felt I
could use Bridgewater as a backup if
your starter is prone to injuries or
just in general I think that he is a
when Bridgewater was healthy before his
injury he loved the buckets to a playoff
he looks like he's back healthy now so
go fishes hit last night to his legs
bounce back played well so I think it's
a great excellent trade partner for
someone who need a really viable option
number two well that would be somewhat
ironic if Bridgewater whose knee injury
was the one that created the Sam
Bradford Nesta need in Philly that led
to the Carson Wentz ascension and a
Super Bowl run that Nick Foles finished
off that if when sand falls aren't ready
its Bridgewater who's the one who's
acquired that would be quite a ribbon on
that story now interesting you mentioned
about the vicious hit that that
Bridgewater took to his knees it looked
like one of those late hits roughing the
passer wasn't called we have seen some
inconsistency from the officials
preseason it's preseason for them as
well where do you stand on the helmet
rule here so far Jeff what we've seen
through last night I think the call last
night they determined that he was pushed
into the back of his legs it looked like
if that could have been the case by the
left-half let's talk dollars he
determined full speed the helmet rule
there was one egregiously bad call last
night I think that in the rest of them
up in preview and early we're aware it's
going to be out here's a deal every year
is a new rule a new emphasis it gets
over call in the preseason a couple
years ago hands to the face is the big
thing and my brother got flustered she
saw a flag two or three times in one
game the first game there were five to
seven called a game in the preseason for
hands let's face it Susie they were done
because the refs adjusted their
preseason to and the one thing that
worries me about this whole more
anything else and it's for the part I
think properly most of the time is the
the runner lowering himself so runners
are taught yet protect their knees by
lowering themselves in Austin Tebow your
shoulders your head goes with it
the Safety's gonna make a tackle with
your legs and you hit help but the
helmet because you've owed yourselves I
don't think it's fair to the defender to
call that and this is why I'm against
adding water we play but I think you
might have to review these I don't know
how do that because otherwise it's never
gonna be calling the running back
probably or the runner I should say and
these safeties and linebackers are gonna
keep getting this call bought that but
it's not spared some of these are legit
when a guy watch himself into a he'll
mother we see those happening those are
okay this is the hint one out of the
game but those hips I think we don't
want out again that's part of what's
happening and otherwise I don't know how
defenders will tackle guys Jeff thanks
for the call certainly on the day right
before Shabbos thank you for the call
really appreciate it
good let's chat again real soon Jeff
really enjoy as always you got Jeff
Schwartz at GE o FF Schwartz the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience